Với kinh nghiệm về trạng của một đại biểu khối khối 2 quan li tích khoám bị bà và mùi búng, ông trình nọt phương,
huy vình bán chấp hành nạn bầu tính tây nình, ví thử đại huy vường gọi dầu,
chú tịch hồi đồng dân chân phương gọi dầu, tiếp tục được tính giềm,
giới thiệu ứng cử đại huy khối khoám bị sấu.
Sự kết hợp giữa trị thức truyền mô của một tính sĩ quy hoặc và bán lĩnh
tôi liền khoám quyền năm tin nghỉ trường chiến hồng với hương 3 giềm kỳ là tình
huy vình, thay lần làm vý thư huy vui tên viên và gọi dầu.
Mà lần làm giảm đốc các sở sẽ dừng sở kết hợp và đủ tư sở tài chính.
Chính là nền tạn để ông thực hiện chú tinh hành động để tâm huy của mình.
Công hai nhiệm kỳ của khối khoám bị bà và mùi búng, ông trình nọt phương,
đã để lại nhiều giấu ứng đậm nét với phải gọi là huy vình huy vàn khoa học công nghệ và mùi trường
của khối khối. Ông được cứu trị đánh giá cao, mời những phát biểu sách sảo, thẳng thẳng,
và có tính phản bị cao trong các viên thảo luận về xe dừng phát lục.
Nặc biệt là các giữa ăn lực xe dừng, lực huy hoặc và lực lực đại,
lực kính chúc, lực mang hành quan bản huy phạm phát lục.
Không chỉ để lại giáo ứng tại nghị trường mà còn la tính nói sắc sảo trên truyền thông.
Sự tháng kháng khi được kiến nghị cứu trị thẳng tâm đỉnh báo kiếc của ông,
đã tạo áp lực tích trường thuốc lấy các bộ ngàn giải quyết viết điểm khó khăn,
bồi đáp điểm tinh và khi bóng lớn từ nhân dân.
Cái nghiệm từ việc thăm gia giám sắc tự cao các quân trình tồng điểm quốc gia
và các chính sách phát triển kinh tính xả hồi,
đã tiếp ông có các dình báo quát thật diễn để báo về quyền lời chính đáng của nhân dân.
Những bài học huy vống về kỹ năng lắm nè,
tổng hợp và chuyển tải thời thử của sống vào các quyết sách của quốc hồi,
chính là hành trang quái trong nhất mà ông mang theo trong lần tứng tử này.
Kể thường những thành tử từ các dình kỳ trước trong truy trình thành động khoám buổi sống,
ông trình ngọt phương, khánh định các trong tâm.
Chỉ nhất, việc tấu trong thành vượt tổ quốc của nhân dân của ý hương pháp,
giềm chỉnh chấp hành trường lối của bạn, chính sách phạt lịch của nhận đối.
Tường xin dự mối, nhưng hãy mặt thiết hồi cứ truyền,
lắm nè và tiếp tục đầy đấu phản ảnh Trung thật,
kẹp thời sống tư, mẹn dọng chính sáng của nhân dân của khỏi và gạc kêu quan và thông quề.
Điều hải, thử thêm một cật nghiêm tốt,
chật kiện hồi hỏa trung trên hộ gầm của khỏi.
Không ngừng năng cao phóng lần, năng lực và tính thành cũng sử nhất dân của người dài miếng hố khỏi.
Đủ đọng tất cật, thăm ra xin dân hồi hỏa hoàn tỉnh hẹn thông quốc lần.
Năng cao chực lưu hỏa gầm lập pháp và giám sách,
vứa phòng bảo đám quyền là ở học pháp, chính đáng của nhân dân.
Không có nhiều tân của khu truy của các cơ quan, chính cử.
Chúnga, khoang tâm xấu sắc, đến các chiếm đầy ăn xen sau khi khiến tính tế bình dẫn,
tục đẩy phá gịch ám, năng cao chú nhập và chục lưu cuộc sống của người dân.
Màu làm sự pháp kính hài hoa, giều tăng tưởng thích tế và tính bộ trong văn xa hoi.
Tuy tư, bối dịch giám là tính vuy nhiên, tư sẽ cùng thập của ý và giống phương,
tập trung lần đau tục kìa cắt người quyết của đảng, năng cao chục lưu không tắt xí dành.
Pháp kính tế xa hoi, giữ dựng hộ phòng lần, đánh và phật đánh dự phương.
Trang gần tiếp xúc cửa trây theo dành, dựng mối dịch ngày cho mình xin chặt trẻ hói nhấn dân.
Trẻ hỏi trong đó và giám xác việc gà quyết cắt kinh người của kết trây.
Màu đám các ý kính được xem xác, sự lý nghiêm tốt, lúc quyết định phó bật.
Màn thất cả lòng nghiệp quyết và kinh nghiệm đã tất lý,
tôi nhuyên quyết tâm khoảng thần thuốc dịch bộ của người dài biểu dân.
Đặt lại đi bình thân phá kì vọng bà trứ trì tính nhà, đại người cấm.